Now, you were asking me about Ham being
naked.
>> Oh, no. Noah being naked.
>> No, I still like it when you said Ham,
bro, because you know, I don't know
something about you and Ham. Are you
ready?
>> All right. All right.
>> Okay. Let's read. Genesis 9. We're going
to start at verse 20. Then Noah began to
be a man of the land and planted a
vineyard, and he drank of the wine and
became drunk and uncovered himself
inside his tent. Now, someone will say,
"Well, why did Noah get drunk?" Well
guys, this is after the flood
and now things have changed. The
atmosphere has changed. Things have
changed are not the same. A worldwide
flood has now changed. The atmosphere of
the earth and the conditions are now
different than what before the flood.
So, as Noah is planting a vineyard, he's
learning as he goes along that when you
have now fruit of the vine and it's
fermented, it can get you drunk. So,
he's learning. And so, now he learned
the hard way. Uhoh, I better be careful
drinking the fruit of the vine and
allowing it to ferment because it's
going to get me drunk. Okay, everyone
got it?
Everyone got it right?
You got it now? So far, Lee, I gotta
hear you do it before the rest.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I hear.
>> Okay. Now, here's what he's referring
to. Then Ham
>> the father of Canaan saw the nakedness
of his father and told his two brothers
outside. But Shem and Jeffth took the
garment and laid it upon both their
shoulders and walked backward and
covered the nakedness of their father.
And their faces were turned backwards.
So they did not see their father's
nakedness. Then Noah woke from his wine
and he knew what his youngest son had
done to him. So he said, "Cursed be
Canaan, servant of servants. He shall be
to his brothers."
Now here's the thing.
>> Is he cursing Canaan or is he
prophesying?
Is he telling? Is he prophesying in
advance what will happen to Canaan? What
will happen to Shem and Jeff? It's a
prophecy. How do I know? Because he goes
on to say, and he said, "Blessed be
Yahweh, the God of Shem. Let Canaan be
his servant. May God enlarge Jeffith.
Let him dwell in tents of Shem and let
Canaan be a servant." He's prophesying.
This is what's going to happen. Canaan
will be cursed and he'll be enslaved by
the sons of Shem. The Canaanites were
conquered by the Israelites, the sons of
Shem.
Everyone got it?
May God enlarge Jeff and let him dwell
in tents of Shem and let Canaan be a
servant. So these are prophecies of what
will happen to his grandson and his two
sons. Canaan will be cursed and enslaved
by Shem where Jeff will be influenced
and sharing the blessings of Shem.
Right? Shem. You everyone got it? Did
you get it, sir? Before I move on.
>> Yeah, I got it.
>> The real question is what does it mean
that Ham exposed the nakedness of his
father? All right. Ham exposed the
nakedness of his father. Now the sons of
Noah who went out of the ark were Shem
and Ham and Jeffith. And Ham was the
father of Canaan. Ham was the father of
Canaan. These three were the sons of
Noah. And from these the whole earth was
scattered abroad. Now you can read this
in one of two ways. You can read this as
Ham had fathered Canaan when they came
off the ark or this is what we call a
retrospective
perspective. Meaning when Ham did what
he did, Canaan was not born yet. But the
writer who's writing after the fact,
writing after the fact is aware that
later Ham will father Canaan. Everyone
with me here? Let's go a little deep.
>> With me there?
>> Yeah, I'm following. Okay, there's two
ways of reading it. That when they came
out of the ark, Ham
Ham's wife gave birth to Canaan, so he's
already alive. Or it can be a
retrospective perspective, meaning that
since Ham would eventually father
Canaan, the author is noting that his
son was Canaan, who wasn't born at the
time, but came later because this is the
son that will end up being cursed
because Noah curses him.
Okay? One of two ways, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So now there are two ways of
interpreting this. So, I'm just giving
you two ways, guys. So, listen
carefully. Lord, increase our numbers
for your glory, not for my praise. May
we be content with one because this is
important. I'm going to give you the two
ways people interpret this. Two ways.
Okay. Number one.
Number one, Ham saw his father in a
drunken stouper naked and
having just humiliated himself. So, Ham
mocked him. Hey, hey guys, look at my
dad. Haha.
And so
Shem and Jeff, not wanting to mock their
father in his drunken stouper where he's
there naked, fully naked, humiliated,
honor their father by covering him. So
when then
Noah woke up, he realized what happened.
So he blesses Shem and Jeff, but he
curses Canaan. But then the question is,
why curse Kanan when Kanan didn't sin?
>> Yeah. And that's the question I had.
>> Exactly. I want to get there.
>> Yeah.
>> So then you're left with, okay, if
that's the reason, why not curse Ham?
Why curse Canaan?
Why curse him? What did Canaan do?
Now the second explanation, I'm giving
you two interpretations. Don't condemn
me. Whatever you feel that is the right
one, seek the Holy Spirit to confirm it.
But I'm telling you the two
interpretations.
Okay. Now, with this said, if we take
the view that Canaan hasn't been born
when Ham exposed his father's nakedness.
Now, this is going to get controversial,
but remember, we believe Moses wrote
Genesis. Moses wrote Genesis,
>> right?
>> So, the same Moses is going to then
explain the things that are happening in
Genesis later on in the giving of the
law. A lot of things in Genesis,
right, will be mentioned that later are
elaborate in the law. For example, I'll
give you an example.
Noah was told to bring seven clean
animals and birds in the ark. Seven
clean. And then on the altar, he offered
seven clean animals and birds. Well,
hold on. The list of clean and unclean
animals comes in Leviticus 11,
Deuteronomy 14. But they're already
mentioned here.
Genesis 8:20-21. Then Noah built an
altar to Yahweh and took of every clean
animal and every clean burn and offered
burnt offerings on the altar. Well,
wait. The distinction between clean and
unclean animals comes later in Leviticus
11 and Deuteronomy 14. Are you ready?
But they already know about clean and
unclean animals and birds even though
they're allowed to eat anything. Why?
Because Genesis is the foundation for
what's to come later. And so those who
are now living at time Moses and read
what Moses writes will understand all of
this. Now when a Jew or an Israelite
reads that Noah offered clean animals
and birds, they already know what these
clean animals and birds are and what
unclean animals birds and unclean, you
know, unclean animals and birds happen
to be. Oh, so he didn't offer swine or
he didn't offer an eagle or a rat. These
are unclean.
And Noah already knew what burnt
offerings were.
Are you seeing the pattern here? You
guys want me to go deep, right?
You get it? You understand how deep it's
getting?
>> Yeah, it's really deep.
>> The Old Testament
is based on Genesis. Genesis is a
foundation. A lot of things that Moses
will then expound on later
were already commands, facts known long
before Moses, known for centuries.
Already Noah knew about burnt offerings.
And he already knew to offer clean
animals and birds as opposed to unclean
ones. Abraham knew about burnt
offerings. They even knew about giving
tithes. They knew about giving a tenth
because Abraham gave a tenth to Melzdc
and Jacob swore he would give a tenth a
tithe to God if God protected him. They
even know they even know about the lever
marriage. What do I mean? In Deuteronomy
25 to10, we're told that if I am married
and I die childless, then my brother
must marry my widow and have a son for
me to continue my line. And if he
refuses to, then she takes her shoe and
points it to me and say, "What a
disgrace I am that I don't care to
continue my brother's line." But that
law was already observed in Genesis 38.
Are you guys with me? Understand what
I'm talking about? Already in Genesis
38, this law was known. So what you find
later in the law of Moses is him
cottifying
commands, practices already known and
observed for centuries.
And you're going to see the point so
far. You're getting it tuli.
>> Yeah, I'm following.
>> Okay, watch this law right here.
Deuteronomy 25:5-10.
If brothers live together and one of
them dies and has no son, then the wife
of the one who died shall not be married
outside the family to a strange man. her
husband's brother shall go into her,
take to her to himself as a wife, and
perform the duty of a husband's brother
to her. And it will be that the
firstborn whom she bears will shall
assume the name of his dead brother, so
that his name will not be blotted out
from Israel. But if the man does not
desire to take his brother's wife, then
his brother's wife shall come up to the
gate to the elders and say, "My
husband's brother refuses to raise up a
name for his brother in Israel. He'd
rather have his brother's name wiped
out. He's not willing to perform the
duty of a husband's brother to me." Then
elders of a city shall summon and speak
to him. And if he stands and says, "I do
not do not desire to take her, then his
brother's wife shall come to him in the
sight of the elders and pull his sandal
off." So his sandal right his foot and
spit in his face, and she shall answer
and say, "Thus it is done to the man who
does not build up his brother's house.
And in Israel his name shall be called,
the house of him whose sandals removed."
But now watch already at the time of
Judah and Jacob. Genesis 38. Watch
Genesis 38. Now it happened at that time
that Judah went down from his brothers
and turned aside to a certain Adulomite
whose name was Haidra. And Judah saw
there a daughter of a certain Canaanite
whose name was Shua. And he took her and
went into her. So she conceived and bore
a son and named him.
Then she conceived again and bore a son
and she named him on. And she bore still
another son and she named him Sheila.
And it was at that she bore him. Now
then Judah took a wife for his firstborn
and her name was Tamar. But Ir Judah's
firstborn was evil in the sight of
Yahweh. So Yahweh put him to death. Then
Judah said to Anan, "Go into your
brother's wife and perform your duty as
a brother-in-law to her and raise up a
seed for your brother." Oh, so they knew
about this command.
>> Yeah, I see that.
>> Deuteronomy 25:5-10 says, "If I die
childless, then my brother has to have a
child for me. If not, then he'll be
humili embarrassed because he's allowing
my name to be wiped out. But Judah
already knew this because he's saying to
Onan, "Hey, your brother died. Go into
his wife. Sire a child for her." But now
Onan was evil. And Onan knew that the
seed would not be his. And it happened
that when he went in to his brother's
wife, he wasted it on the ground in
order not to give seed to his brother.
In other words, he did quite interrupt
us. He didn't want to get her pregnant.
I don't want to have a child for my
brother. So when God saw that but what
he did was displeasing in the sight of
Yahweh. So he put him to death also.
Then Judah said to his daughter-in-law
tomorrow live as a widow in your
father's house until my son Sheila grows
up because now it's his duty to sire a
child for he thought I'm afraid lest he
also die like his brothers. So tomorrow
went and lived in her father's house.
Okay. Did you see the point if you're
listening and not going to sleep? Do you
see how a lot of the commands that Moses
later wrote down, already known, already
observed, already practiced for
centuries by the patriarchs and their
children before Moses, even by Noah? All
right. So now, what's that got to do
with
ham?
You ready now?
>> Yeah, I'm ready.
>> What's that got to do with ham? Shout
out to eat some turkey. It's healthier
for you. Ready?
>> Ready.
>> Okay. So, if we assume that Canaan is
not born yet, but the writer Moses
coming after Ham eventually fathered
Canaan. And now Noah, Noah
and Ham
when they have this encounter, Canaan is
not born yet. But Moses still reminding
you that Hamthea Canaan because Canaan
is important to the discussion. So now
let's go with nakedness. Then Ham the
father Canaan saw the nakedness of his
father and told his two brothers
outside. Shem and Jeff took the garment
and laid it upon both their shoulders
and walked backward and covered the
nakedness of their father and their
faces were turned backward so they did
not see their father's nakedness. Now
Moses who wrote this, let's see
Leviticus 188. Same Moses who wrote this
Genesis then mentions the sins of the
Canaanites. Leviticus 18. Let me show
you the entire chapter because I know
how you guys are. You're skeptical. He
says, "When you go into the land of
Canaan, don't do what the Canaanites do
or what the Egyptians did. It's because
of these sins the Canaanites will be
destroyed." Now, who are the Canaanites?
>> Uh the descendants of him.
>> Okay? So, the Canaanites are the sons of
Canaan. Right.
>> Right. So notice centuries later we have
the Canaanites
living in the land of Canaan named after
their father theology Canaan. So Canaan
settled and his descendants live there.
So it's the land of Canaan. They're the
Canaanites. So now the Israelites or the
sons of Shem will dispossess them just
like Noah prophesied. Right.
>> Right.
>> Right. Canaan be the servant of Shem.
Right.
>> Right. Right. And the Israelites are the
sons of Shem and they're now going to
dispossess and ensnare the Canaanites.
So the prophecy is being fulfilled,
right?
>> Right. So the other inter interpretation
would be um it's like a prophecy.
>> But why a prophecy that Canaan is
cursed? You're going to get it there.
Notice what the Canaanites would do. You
shall not do according to what is done
in the land of Egypt where you live. Nor
are you to do according to what is done
in the land of Canaan. So look at what
the Canaanites are doing where I'm
bringing you. You shall not walk in
their statutes. You are to do my
judgments and keep my statutes to walk
in them. I am Yahweh your God. So you
shall keep my statutes and my judgments
which if a man does them, he shall live
by them and I'm Yahweh. Now notice
Canaan's descendants the kind of sins
they commit that God is saying because
of these sins I'm going to punish them.
None of you shall approach any blood
relative of his to uncover nakedness.
Okay. Now, there's that word, right?
>> Right.
>> I am Yahweh. So, what it does it mean to
uncover someone's nakedness? You shall
not uncover the nakedness of your
father. Is that what Ham did?
>> Right.
>> But what is your father's nakedness?
It's your mother's nakedness.
You shall not uncover the nakedness of
your father. That is the nakedness of
your mother. She is your mother. You are
not to uncover her nakedness. You shall
not uncover the nakedness of your
father's wife. It is your father's
nakedness. To uncover your father's
nakedness means to sleep with your
stepmother or your mother.
>> Wow. That's
>> Now, what is the punishment if you do
that? Leviticus 20:11. If there is a man
who lies with his father's wife, has
sex, he has uncovered his father's
nakedness. Both of them shall surely be
put to death. Their blood guiltiness is
upon them.
Do you understand it?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. If we read,
if we read
Genesis in light of Moses, Ham exposing
his father's nakedness in the language
of Moses means he saw his mother naked.
But it's more than seeing. It's to have
sex with your mother. What do you think
the implication is?
>> So it's a prophecy.
>> Not only a prophecy, but why prophecy
that na Canaan will be cursed? So the
implication is Canaan is cursed because
he is the incestuous seed of Ham
exposing his father's nakedness by
getting his mother pregnant. That's why
the Canaanites following the pattern of
their ancestor continued in incest.
They're following the pattern of their
ancestor. Canaan is the result of
incest. So they indulge in incest.
Well, were their sins in Leviticus 18?
>> Incest.
>> Where do you think they picked that up
from?
>> From him.
>> Like father like son, right?
>> Yeah. Like father said. So since
Canaan's origin is incestuous,
it's not a surprise that his seed, his
descendants are all committing incest.
Father sleeping with daughter, mother
sleeping with son, son sleeping with
stepmother, daughter sleeping with
stepfather, and on and on it goes. So
that's why the Canaanites are cursed
because God is showing Noah the cursed
future of this cursed incestuous seed.
But God Moses is writing it in a way
that you have to decipher its meaning by
reading Genesis in light of what comes
later. Because Moses is careful to write
in such a way where he doesn't
completely shame and disgrace Noah for
what his son did to his mother, Noah's
wife. And so he's going to use the
language of nakedness, which later on he
explains. So that means that Canaan
was conceived later after Hammet exposed
his father's name by sleeping his
mother, getting pregnant. And then after
Canaan is born, he then prophesied. So
this is a period of time that occurred
which now the author is condensing.
He's taking what would have taken years
to happen, but he's condensing it.